after you have launched your apis on
apigee you will want to ensure they are
performing as expected and services are
not interrupted this is where api
monitoring comes in it provides near
real-time insights into api traffic and
performance to help you quickly diagnose
and solve issues as they arise
one of the main purposes of api
monitoring is to keep you informed of
unusual events or patterns such as
spikes in traffic or latencies it
enables you to create notification
alerts of changes in api traffic so you
can take action before customers are
affected
increase api availability
reduce the time to diagnose an issue use
http error codes to speed diagnosis and
isolate problem areas quickly by
investigating errors performance and
latency issues and their source
it's important to note that api
monitoring only retains data for the
last 60 days this is because there may
be personally identifiable information
contained in your data and so it is
deleted per the google privacy policy
after that period
[Music]
api monitoring is available in the
navigation bar under analytics it
provides three different views allowing
you to display timelines of recent api
traffic data
display recent tree maps of data
and investigate using tables of api
traffic data showing http fault codes by
time status and source by proxy
in each of the views you have the same
options you can change the view select
the desired graphs and filter by the
environment region and or proxy by using
the respective dropdowns you can also
adjust the period to analyze a
particular time range
once you have identified a particular
issue you can create an alert to be
notified of the incident more on that
later let's continue with our overview
in the timeline view you have graphs
showing total traffic requests during
one minute intervals error rates as a
percentage of total traffic and latency
450 90 95 and 99 percentiles you can
drill down into each for more details
by hovering over the graphs you can see
data values at any point in time
data points are measured at one minute
intervals
the recent view enables you to view tree
maps of the volume of traffic by
incident error rate and latency
it displays a proxy traffic as blocks
that represent the volume of the traffic
by the size of the box
the color of the block in each graph
indicates the relative sizes of the
number of incidents error rate and the
maximum 50th percentile latency
clicking on a block displays the
distribution in the right pane by http
status codes fault codes fault source
and region
hovering over a block displays the proxy
name total traffic and error rate
the investigate view displays pivot
tables of metrics and attributes for all
api traffic to help you compare activity
for different metrics
by default the investigate view displays
three tables fault code by time fall
code by status code and fault source by
proxy
as in the other views you can select any
combination of tables to aid in your
investigation there are more tables to
choose from in this view
selecting a cell with a value shows the
distribution in the pane on the right as
it did in the recent view
you can select the pivot table to change
its orientation to get a different
perspective
now that we understand the different
views let's take a quick look at alerts
where you can configure notifications to
be sent to your preferred communication
channels such as email or sms etc
alerts are triggered when a specified
event or condition is met which are
called incidents
let's create an alert clicking on the
alert link takes us to the gcp console
where we configure alerts and
notifications for example to set up an
alert for high traffic volume you first
select add condition and then select the
resource type for the target
then select a metric such as proxy
request cumulative request
next select aggregator as sum
and then a period of one minute
clicking add takes us back to the wizard
where we can proceed to the next steps
select an existing notification channel
from the drop down and be sure to check
mark notify an incident closure to know
when the alert clears
enter a descriptive alert and
instructions such as a documentation
link
when an incident is fired you'll get a
notification and when things return to a
healthy state you'll get another
notification that the incident has been
cleared
back in the gcp console you'll be able
to see the history of incidents that
occurred specifically when they were
opened and when they were closed
and there you have it a quick
walkthrough of how to use the power of
api monitoring and how it can keep your
api program running smoothly and your
api consumers happy
if you found this episode helpful
community you can subscribe to learn
about more of our episodes on getting
started with apogee's api management
toolset cheers
[Music]
you